there are some serious allegations that
have been made involving woody johnson
the owner of the new york jets currently
the u.s ambassador
to great britain and it all started
chris
as a report from the new york times
that president trump allegedly
right tried to get woody johnson to try
to get the british government to try to
steer
the british open to the trump turnberry
resort
in scotland right and there there are
a lot of potential disconnects
in that stream of the attempt
to get from you know the president
wanting it to it actually happening i
don't know how practical of a project
that was i don't know how much
influence woody johnson was going to
have i don't know how much influence the
british government would have had
i don't know that there's somebody
sitting in an office somewhere
within the british government who can
press a button and make it happen but
that's how it all started that was the
story that emerged
on wednesday and this sentence appeared
near the bottom of the article in the
new york times
there have been complaints that woody
johnson complimented the appearance of
female employees during staff meetings
and after interviewing a candidate for
the deputy chief of mission position
he asked a colleague whether the person
who was interviewed
was jewish now it was kind of a hard
right turn from why they were even there
right but it laid the foundation for
what came
on thursday what came on thursday was a
report from cnn
that was focused specifically on
workplace behavior
of woody johnson while serving as the
u.s ambassador to the uk
and there are allegations of both racial
and sexist comments made by woody
johnson again these are allegations
cnn cites multiple unnamed sources and
it appears that these allegations were
ultimately
reported to an inspector general that's
the mechanism within the federal
government whenever there's
some sort of a complaint to be made an
inspector general
receives the complaints investigates is
needed so you know this isn't something
that was just being
presented directly to cnn there was some
internal mechanism that was activated
where people made these complaints and
here are
the specific complaints that were made
the and again this is all according to
cnn
based upon multiple sources woody
johnson made racist generalizations
about black men and questioned why the
black community celebrates
black history month there was a 2018
event for black history month
johnson reportedly quote appeared
agitated and asked if the audience would
be
quote a whole bunch of black people end
quote three unnamed sources told cnn
that johnson
quote argued that black fathers didn't
remain with their families and that was
the real challenge
one source told cnn that an official who
overheard the comments was stunned
and that the incident was documented and
reported another source said that woody
johnson
has said some pretty sexist racist
things
uh and also there were allegations of
cringe-worthy comments made
about female employees about
the appearance of female employees and
there's one quote specifically it was a
struggle to get
the ambassador on board for an event for
international women's day
with johnson asking why he had to do a
quote feminist event
end quote that is the gist
that is the extent right that is the
universe of what's been reported pretty
serious
and uh pretty serious if true
so i i reached out to the league
as soon as i saw the cnn report
and the league's comment was we're aware
of the report we would refer you to the
state department well the state
department has
defended woody johnson and has
essentially without specifically denying
the accuracy of the allegations has just
said he's doing a great job and we stand
behind him 100 percent
i asked the jets if they had a statement
at the time they didn't in the interim
there was a denial from woody johnson
that was posted on twitter and then
last evening late afternoon early
evening the jets issued a statement
that they're aware of the allegations
against ambassador johnson which he
specifically denied in the following
statement earlier today they then go on
to quote his denial
i have followed the ethical rules and
requirements in my office at all time
these false claims of insensitive
remarks about race and gender are
totally inconsistent
with my long-standing record and values
the statement goes on to say that since
the johnson family became aware of the
new york became owners of the new york
jets the organization has consistently
and actively supported engaged and
encouraged the development of
many different social justice diversity
women's and inclusion
initiatives so the league
the league didn't issue a denial per se
the league steered everyone to the state
department which kind of denied it right
the jets have denied it woody johnson
has denied it
so i don't know where it goes
from here it's it's it's it's like so
many other things today the allegation
comes up
yeah a statement is issued and then it
just kind of goes away
i i don't i don't know what happens next
but it it was one of the biggest stories
of the day and it's something that
at what finally is a fairly slow time in
the nfl although it's the calm before
the storm
this kind of hit and and it it cries out
to be dealt with because again if the
allegations are true they're extremely
serious yeah they're serious i mean and
you're hearing it from multiple people
and you know notable you know
trustworthy news sources in the new york
times the cnn i mean yeah this is
serious
and i understand the nfl wanted to refer
you know the media to the state
department because right now they're
looking at it like
yes we know he's an owner of our
football team but he did this on the
duty of the state department
so you should talk to them this is their
issue right now and
you know you know i just it's it's
troubling
it's troubling because these are
powerful people these are people that
run our league
and of course employ a lot of females
and african-american males and it just
leads to an it leads to an uneasy work
environment
and what stinks about that is we're in
an uneasy
life environment right now in our
country with this conversation too so
it's sensitive
and of course we have an administration
that is always
linked to this type of talk so i don't
know and i don't mean to go
on the political part here but sorry
politics keep coming to football
tell them to stay out of football or
just tell them to stay on one side
but that that to me is the troubling
thing this is just you know what is this
time
9 ninety seven thousand eight hundred
and forty five
that we've heard somebody from this
administration you know
linked allegedly you know to
uh racist or just insensitive comments
it bothers me mike you know it does i
mean
listen i had a guy that i used a guy
that i i know it does
none of that matters none of that
matters what matters is
the allegations at hand involving woody
johnson it doesn't matter whether the
president who appointed him to that
position was republican or democrat
this needs to be dealt with and that's
my question
what will happen next will it just
fizzle out like the 15 former female
employees who have alleged they were
sexually harassed working for the
washington organization that hit last
thursday one week ago
the weekend provided a hard reset and
now there's nothing
it's not even discussed it's not even
mentioned i mean that's kind of the way
things are now it's like okay
here here's something that happened that
if it's true it's bad
they deny it and what do we do where do
we go
and and so the question i have is what
will the nfl really do about this will
the nfl
actively investigate this or will the
nfl just say it didn't happen on our
watch and the fritz pollard alliance
which is in place to champion diversity
specifically as it relates to coaching
and general manager positions and the
fritz apollo alliance has done some
great work over the years
up to and including creating and
enforcing the rooney rule
there was a statement issued early
thursday morning by the fritz pollard
alliance that reads as follows
the fritz paul alliance is deeply
troubled by allegations of insensitive
remarks about race and gender made by
jets owner woody johnson
allegations of this nature if true are
damaging to the social fabric of our
country and cannot be tolerated
while only allegations at this point
they are serious
we call on the nfl to carefully monitor
the situation and if the allegations
have merit to take appropriate action
and work toward
rooting such sentiments from the nfl
community now they they stopped short of
saying
that if the allegations are true woody
johnson should no longer be the owner of
the team and that's a separate issue
because the first question is
are they true and what will the nfl be
doing to explore whether or not they are
true
and you know the contrast here chris
when you think about
what forced donald sterling to sell the
la clippers several years ago
there was no investigation to be done he
was recorded
saying horribly racist things in the
privacy of his own home
and that was enough to force him to sell
here we have
statements allegedly made in a public
workplace
in government service by someone who's
the owner of an nfl team
that the next step if we're going to do
this logically the next step is to ask
what is going to be done to explore
and investigate whether or not the
statements
the allegations are true or do we just
say
the report is what it is he denies it
and that's that so i think the fritz
pollard alliance in a tactful way
is trying to agitate for the nfl
to investigate this find out what's
there right they've investigated air
pressure in footballs they've
investigated allegations of bounties
they've investigated
bullying situations in miami the nfl
gets involved and investigates now it'll
be interesting to see if the jets
hire their own lawyer to investigate the
situation like daniel snyder did last
week and the league just says
okay the league needs to get involved
here that's what the fritz pollard
alliance is saying
the league needs to appoint someone to
investigate this independently that's
what needs to happen next
if they're going to treat this situation
the way that we've seen them treat
other situations involving players
coaches
and other non-owners well okay i mean
you know
you know the cba and things better than
me here and or just the agreements in
general
the contracts throughout the nfl does
the nfl have jurisdiction to kind of
like
investigate something like this does a
state department official or people that
were might have
uh been witnesses to this can the nfl
have access to those people that's
that's what would be my first
question the first thing you got to do
is try right and at a minimum at a
minimum
you can make freedom of information act
requests there's certain information
that you can obtain
from the inspector general that way i
would assume now there are going to be
exceptions and limitations
but there are ways for the nfl to try to
get information that would otherwise be
public
publicly available the nfl can can
talk to woody johnson i mean look they
they bring players in all the time for
personal conduct policy investigations
yeah and they confront them with
allegations there's differences hang on
let me finish
will you ask me a question let me finish
and they bring them in
and they sit them down and they ask them
questions and they assess whether or not
they think they're telling the truth
so at a minimum what you do is you bring
woody johnson
over from britain you sit him down in
the commissioner's office
you ask him questions like lawyers do
all the time
and you have people in the room who
observe his demeanor
and come to the conclusion as to whether
or not he's telling the truth now
you know you may be limited in how much
detailed information you can get
but you try to get all that first like
every lawyer
you want to know the answer to the
question before you ask it but you want
to see what he says
is he truthful does he seem truthful
does he seem
contrite if contrition is necessary is
he going to concede anything along these
lines
the the point is this they do it with
players all the time
are they going to do it now that this
cloud has been raised
over an owner who isn't currently
actively running a team
but still owns the team that's the
question and we'll find out whether or
not the nfl is going to take action in
that regard well i hope they do i mean i
hope that
you know like you're talking about that
they bring him in talk to him try to
figure out
uh you know the story or hear his side
of the story
and and read body language and things
like that but the the true facts of the
matter is there's two different sets of
rules it's just that's the unfortunate
thing about the nfl
you know if you got an owner and a
player to do the same exact
you know crime or or or you know
injustice or whatever
the player's gonna be reprimanded you
know more severely than the owner it's
just the
that's the the proof's in the putting
the pudding there and then
okay yeah great i mean woody woody
johnson's not going to admit to any of
this when the nfl brings him over
it's it's going to be denied deny deny
so yeah they have a conversation with
them he says no i didn't do it they read
his body language they what are they
gonna go like
where we recommend you can't own the
team anymore because we read by
bad body language in that meeting so you
know this is another part of you know i
do you're right it's gonna get swept
under the rug unless some reporter or
somebody out there continues to dig and
they find out more information
or maybe this opens the dam of oh he's
done
other things you know that are unethical
on the job
as well as far as being the ambassador
over there and doing those things i mean
it's one of the two things it looks like
it's
going to disappear or it goes on there's
another way that this can go
you could have the new york times the
washington post si.com
any other major media outlet with the
resources and the inclination to do it
to begin talking to former jets
employees to see if they can determine
whether or not there were
similar statements made while he was
running the jets because
i i think common sense would tell us he
just didn't all of a sudden decide to
start acting this way in the workplace
when he became the u.s ambassador
to great britain that that there
probably would be a trail of breadcrumbs
during the time that he was actively
serving as the owner of the jets so at
least there is some benefit
in trying to track down former employees
to see if anyone will
go on the record or off the record and
make these claims now
now within the not too distant past the
nfl
has squeezed an owner to sell his team
and that happened when
panthers founder jerry richardson it
came out that there were multiple
settlement agreements with individuals
who had worked for him
involving allegations of workplace
misconduct made
directly at him where
people who had signed non-disclosure
agreements breached the agreements and
spoke to si.com and it was all
laid out there and before you know it
jerry richardson's out and in that case
the nfl
did hire an independent or at least as
independent as it ever is an
outside lawyer to go in and investigate
the situation and make some
recommendations
and uh so i think the precedence been
set i mean there is a double standard
that we detect from time to time when it
comes to players versus non-players
but they did set a precedent with how
they handled jerry richardson
and at the end of the day right but for
settlement agreements being signed by
the individuals who had complaints
against jerry richardson there is an
apples to apples element to this
it was employees of the panthers who had
complaints about
things done and or said by jerry
richardson in the workplace
well now you've got employees of the
federal government
who have complaints about things that
were said by woody johnson
in the workplace not the jets workplace
but he's the owner of the jets while
he's in this public workplace
serving as the u.s ambassador to great
britain so
is that happening i think i mean
it's ultimately i mean it's it's people
in the workplace
that he's interacting with that he's
saying things around
and now there's no action involved but
there are words
that are being complained about just
like there were words from jerry
richardson that were being complained
about
the difference is it's not the jets
workplace that's what the nfl has to get
its arms around
yeah and that's that's the i mean how
many
how many owners well and there are
plenty of owners who have other business
interests and i think if you own an nfl
team
and you are engaged in non-nfl business
and you act in a way that undermines
your standing
as an nfl owner yeah that's right arms
the shield you should you personally
i think the person hey look let me just
say this
the personal conduct policy applies to
all players when they aren't at work
so woody johnson's not at work for the
jets
but he's engaging in behavior that
that potentially would trigger the
personal conduct policy so i think that
here's
there's enough there if the nfl wants to
do something about it
there's enough there the question is do
they want to do something about it
or is it going to be like washington
last week where
you get a couple of statements issued
it's clear that the league's going to
defer to the findings of the lawyer
hired by daniel snyder to investigate
daniel snyder surprise surprise what's
the end result of that going to be
what is the league going to do here is
it going to be more like what happened
with jerry richardson
or is it going to be more like what
happened last week with washington
that's what we have to say
i i i i i think they're going to need
more in the nfl before they dive into it
that would just be my you know
and again i i know nothing here this is
just me as a person who's followed
football for a long long time
i i think that they're gonna have to be
more that comes out
before they dive into this right now
it's kind of a
you know he said he said type of thing
and i don't know if there's enough
legitimacy there
uh and i know they found other people
over
in the british government who kind of
you know
uh what do i want to say you know agreed
or agreed with woody johnson too so
there's like both sides there
there's there's people that you know say
yes woody johnson did do these things
but there's also been a few people that
have come out and said no
none of these none of the requests for
the trump at you know scotland turnberry
happened and all that so
i think there's going to have to be more
flesh out of the story i know it doesn't
have apples to apples there the stuff
there's not but the
the stuff about the the british open is
irrelevant i think to this yes
it is yeah yes the the comments
allegedly made in the workplace and
also what are the jets players going to
do about this because with donald
sterling there was kind of a mini revolt
from within the organization where the
players were saying they weren't going
to play for this guy anymore
jamal adams is the only guy who has said
anything about it
and look jamal adams wants out he he
doesn't have the same credibility that
that other players on the roster would
have because it's well documented he
wants to be traded so if he can agitate
for a trade
by making a stink here that he's going
to be more inclined to do it i guess is
what i'm saying yes the other 52 guys on
the roster or
technically 89 guys on the roster it'll
be interesting to see if they have
anything to say and they're going to be
showing up for training camp sooner
rather than later
so uh that will be an interesting facet
to monitor because
if the players begin to speak out
and if the players express concern
that's going to put pressure on the
league
to do something more than just you know
keep your head low your mouth shut and
wait for it all to go away
like everything else tends to do
nowadays so that's kind of where we are
yeah and we'll see how it plays out i'm
going to ask the league
at some point today will there be any
investigation it's one thing to say
we're aware of the reports and we refer
you to the state department it's another
thing to say
will we see the league actively
investigate this the way that the league
investigated
when jerry richardson was accused of
workplace misconduct that ultimately
forced him to sell the team and we're
not saying woody johnson should have to
sell the team
look and maybe maybe he won't have to
sell the team maybe he just never comes
back maybe christopher johnson continues
to run the team right who knows
but but it's it's something that at a
minimum
needs to be addressed beyond here's the
allegation
here's the denial and there's nothing
more we can do about it i think there is
more that the nfl
can do about it and we'll keep an eye on
what it is that the nfl does
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports